nuevo remesó el ministerial en Colombia
a casi 9 meses de haber asumido su cargo
el presidente Gustavo Petro cambió a
siete de sus 18 ministros y a un alto
funcionario de la presidencia así
respondió cuando tres partidos
tradicionales que hacían parte del
gobierno no lo respaldaron en su
criticada reforma a la salud que cursan
el congreso la cual prioriza la atención
primaria y quiere eliminar el manejo por
parte de empresas privadas además Petro
disolvió la coalición gubernamental por
lo que pierde las mayorías en el
legislativo hoy se construye un nuevo
gabinete que ayudará a consolidar el
programa de gobierno programa que será
la base de un acuerdo nacional Franco y
sincero Para seguir trabajando al
servicio de las comunidades de todo el
país uno de los anuncios que más
sorprendió fue el relevo de la ministra
de salud Carolina corcho quien dio la
batalla para defender la reforma a la
salud por otro lado salen el ministro de
hacienda José Antonio Ocampo y de
agricultura Cecilia los dos habían
firmado una carta con críticas a dicha
reforma antes de que fuera presentada
ambos sobrevivieron a la anterior crisis
de gabinete en febrero cuando el
presidente hizo sus tres primeros
cambios otra cara de la actual
modificación ministerial es que tres de
los nuevos funcionarios trabajaron con
Petro cuando él fue alcalde de Bogotá
entre 2012 y 2015 con el nuevo equipo el
primer presidente de izquierda de
Colombia aún tiene un largo camino por
recorrer para lograr su plan de gobierno
denominado el pacto social por el cambio
y actualmente tiene una desfavorabilidad
del 57% casi tres veces mayor que la que
tenía a un mes de iniciar su mandato
[Música]